Oui allô ? Non je ne vous entends pas vous appelez sur une boîte et cette blague est bien bien nulle on est en plein tournage
Malaise tv bonjour ! Bonjour à vous ! Comment allez vous ? Vous n'avez pas quitté cette vidéo après cette magnifique intro et je vous en remercie !
Peuple des internets, aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un jeu pour cette quatorzième ouverture du calendrier de l'avent c'est... heu...
Émoticônes challenge ! Ils ont fait pas mal de version de ça et je trouve celle ci très drôle c'est "smileys word" et "404" qui
fait ça... Je vous donne un exemple très concret jouons ensemble c'est beaucoup plus simple... Catégorie film. Tout le jeu et que en
émoticônes et en catégories et il faut trouver de quoi ça parle
là vous voyez par exemple l'image numéro 1... eh bien il faut deviner le film. Alors qu'est ce qu'on a en émoticônes ?
nous avons quatre tortues, un rat, un point un peu... bagarreur !
et des pizzas... C'est donc... ? "Tortues ninja" le film tortues ninja celle ci elle est facile : un coquillage un requin des dents
des dents de la mer les dents de la mer les dents de la mer oui très bien
il y en a plein comme ça dans toutes les catégories... J'en prends au hasard et on essaie de les trouver ok ? ça c'est quoi c'est...
la catégorie "jeu"... alors il faut retrouver un jeu vidéo
P*tain, je ne suis pas bon du tout je sais pas dans quoi je m'embarque, je ne suis pas bon du tout en jeu vidéo mais
quand même celui ci et celui ci je commence déjà à avoir des doutes
heu... il y avait un jeu... heuuuu
de trucs de ninjas ou fallait couper des fruits
Oui alors, hahahaha ! Bravo sherlock ! Il y a des fruits et un ninja je crois que c'est un jeu de ninja fallait... Comment ça s'appelait ce jeu ? hmm... C'est Quick Ninja...? Non c'est pas quick ninja...
On a un débat avec Loïc qui tourne la vidéo et qui... et qui... la monte d'ailleurs !
Heu je peux vous le prouver parce que là il va faire apparaître des fruits ! Et il a le jeu original que je n'arrive pas à trouver
il est là en train de le mettre en post prod
heuuuu... Comment il s'appelait ? c'était un jeu sur iphone
naaan
et tu dois faire ça avec
voilà, eh bien....
On va passer donc à ce jeu là ! Une étoile... j'ai envie de dire star ! Non je ne suis pas bilingue... et un micro !
Heuu... chanter ?
singstar ? ou un truc comme ça ? bon bref ! vous avez compris que je suis surtout une grosse brel en jeu vidéo ! Passons à la catégorie suivante...
catégorie "séries" ! Bon  là il y a un extraterrestre, un... mec qui...
qui... qui... qui donne un coup de langue comme s'il avait mangé un chat ! Moi spontanément je pense à half
Je sais pas si vous avez connu la série half
Heuu... mais du coup j'ai envie de vérifier sur le... voir si j'ai bon pas parce que bien sûr vous avez toutes les réponses ici...  halff !
joli !  Je suis fier de moi !
1986 à 1990 j'ai une culture très récente... Un dernier pour la route on va aller dans les livres
dans les livres... alors... Une fusée, des extraterrestres, une planète, des gens malades et ils meurent
Et de l'argent
on, on... On se refait un film pour finir ?
Allez ! On se refait un film pour finir... Halala !  Un extraterrestre, un vélo, une lune, un téléphone, une maison...  téléphone maison... E.T. !
je vérifie même pas tellement je suis sûr ! Une douche, un couteau...
"Psychose" d'alfred hitchcock
j'ai beaucoup aimé le principe de ce jeu en fait c'est quand j'ai vu la boîte ça m'a fait kiffer parce que là tu vois
spider man... là... tu sais que c'est...
titanic... ici men in black... Ici Sex and the city... Ici harry potter...J'ai... je trouvais ça très malin en fait comme idée...
Innovateur... j'ai jamais entendu parler d'autres jeux comme ça
donc de fait je me suis dit
ce serait bien de leur en parler parce que ça peut leur plaire... C'est vrai je dis jamais le prix des choses
Combien j'ai payé ça ? J'ai payé ça...Heu la somme exacte
de 10 euros...Voilà...
Je trouve ça sympa
ça se joue entre amis, ou ça peut se faire donc avec des vraies règles pour marquer des points et tout, ou ça peut juste
se faire comme ça entre potes sans chercher à compter les points... Juste chercher à résoudre
l'émoticône challenge j'ai trouvé ça cool vous pouvez me dire si vous aimez bien vous pouvez liker cette vidéo vous pouvez vous abonner à cette
chaîne tout ça se fait d'une manière gratuite
vous pouvez retrouver le lien de ce jeu dans la description le lien est
gratuit
le jeu est payant... J'ai pas d'action, c'est pas un placement de produit. Et vous pouvez revenir sur la chaîne demain matin à 6 heures
pour une nouvelle vidéo parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme ça c'est un calendrier de l'avent salut ciao je m'en vais